pierre n'y est pas dans la sosie cam
[Musique]
mais non mais hasard de dingue pardon
vous êtes
[Rires]
là j'ai découvert une recette de pizza
incroyable et je voulais vous la
partager ce matin sur Virgin Radio ça va
peut-être vous donner des idées la pizza
au couscous
parsemez un peu de semoule avec de
l'agneau c'est magnifique pizza au
couscous
j'aimerais que tu répondes honnêtement
est-ce qu'en 2023 tu continueras à nous
faire vomir tous les matins
[Rires]
Noël
joyeux Noël à tous plein de joie de
tendresse d'humilité bien sûr c'est
important autour d'une table une humble
table avec un bout de pain noir et une
cruche d'eau la cruche c'est moi
toujours tuer la dinde avant de la
farcir mon Dieu elle serait pas contente
allez c'est parti on part prendre le
télésiège
ah je suis pas fait
j'ai affaire à deux givré là